no high net worth individual has
everything in his name let's just put it
that way it's complicated the way things
are on so sometimes people will ask me
they'll be five cars on the drive and
you know girls especially who are naive
to these things will be like which ones
are yours and which ones are Andrews my
honest answer is I don't actually know
let me I have to look at the papers to
work out exactly what but it but it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter the
keys are in this box in that room and we
can drive them whenever we like and we
never argue because there's so many you
know and when you build that abundance
and you build
yourself to the level of wealth me and
Andrew at what are we going to argue
about there were times when we were
kickboxing we didn't have money for food
we used to eat cans of sardines and
there have been times splitting our last
can over plain rice so now people be
like oh that's weird that you share a
house with your brother I'm like it's
weird that you don't
you know I used to share my last can of
food with him and now we can't live in
the same house I've got nine bedrooms
it's not like we're cramped for space
and uh otherwise we just live in two
separate houses with four and a half
bedrooms each and we'll drive to each
other's houses every day it wouldn't
make sense